als food-liebhaber ist es meiner Aufgabe
ein Überblick über den Markt zu behalten
und deshalb muss ich immer mal wieder
bei neuen Restaurants bestellen oder
diese testen mache ich natürlich nicht
weil ich Bock auf geiles essen habe
sondern weil es meine Pflicht ist heute
bestellen wir mal wieder und zwar bei
drei Restaurants die noch nicht bewertet
wurden also bei Restaurants die 0 Sterne
haben das ist immer ein bisschen Glück
oder Pech also entweder hat man
Restaurant was mega gut ist dass man
dann auch gerne mit einer guten Note
bewertet oder eines was vielleicht auch
bald wieder verschwinden wird schauen
wir mal rein was es heute wird und das
cool ist wir werden dabei den ganzen Tag
sparen und zwar wegen dem Partner das
heutigen Videos die drei legen wir mal
los dazu später mehr schauen wir mal ob
wir ein zwei Restaurants finden die noch
nicht bewertet sind also 9,0 Sterne
soweit natürlich nicht wir müssen noch
diese kleine Bewertung da unten drunter
achten wenn die nicht da ist dann können
wir bestellen ich mache es mir auch
manchmal schwierig einfach was zu essen
aber mediterrano Restaurant Kebab
Falafel und Co merma
bei Muso Döner Schnitzel und Burger
gegen Heißhunger so Heißhunger habe ich
ja merke ich mir mal ich merke ich wo
wir bestellen zwei haben wir auf jeden
Fall schon mal mindestens eins brauchen
wir noch darin Pizza alles was der
Gaumen liebt sieht übel aus
ich will so einfach direkt für mich so
aussieht als könnte es nur geil sein oh
geil das wollte ich wirklich die ganze
Zeit testen haben wir schon Leute
geschrieben dass es ein neuer Sushi Spot
für Ferien Köln aufgemacht hat die sind
noch nicht bewährt weil ihr ganz neu
sind das war auch teuer Gurkensalat
diese frischen Minigurken mit Chili
Sesam Dressing 7 €. eigentlich braucht
man das Special die sind aber auch teuer
15 € 14 Euro Samen Mango Dream Roll
Lachs Gurken Avocado Frischkäse und
Mango getoppt mit sesamen ich nehme die
noch einmal lachsmaki und einmal Thun
damit sind wir auch schon bei 8 und 30 €
für diesen minigurensalat die Special
Roll und zweimal Maki sehr teuer besser
ist es auch sehr sehr gut jetzt haben
wir etwas bestellt brauche ich sehr
große Lust hatte und das hat mich ja
jetzt hier bei Mut zur auf den ersten
Blick mit Slogan nicht direkt abgeholt
Döner Schnitzel und Burger gegen
Heißhunger dieses Format ist ja auch da
um Läden eine Chance zu geben die noch
nicht bewertet wurden deshalb machen wir
genau das jetzt Hamburger mit jupi Soße
und Ketchup nein Mini Frühlingsrollen
Mozzarella Sticks Milchreis Tiramisu war
okay das war's nämlich bei der Laden der
bekannt ist für seinen Schnitzel hat
keinen Schnitzel sondern nur Hamburger
und Dönerteller 4,90€ wohlgemerkt als
krasser Gegenpol ein Burger ja aber hat
aber auch finde ich was ehrliches das
ist ja eigentlich ein Cheeseburger laut
Foto da ist der Käse drauf dass man den
so Hamburger nennt wahrscheinlich heißt
er nicht Hamburg sondern Hamburger ein
Hamburger ja dann wohl noch den
Milchreis dazu für eri und zweite
bestellung ist raus suchen wir uns
Restaurant Nummer drei also wir suchen
ein bisschen weiter was es noch gibt sie
klaro heute wird dein Essen heiß
mexikanisch nicht bewertet nicht
bewertet let's go Kameraden
in Knoblauch Olivenöl mit Peperoni und
Cherry Tomaten passt da ich dachte so
geil ein authentischen Mexikaner ja ich
glaube wir gehen am besten ist die klare
Cheeseburger chicken Philipp Burger
[Musik]
Enchiladas Geflügel Rindfleisch Geflügel
Geflügel das ist die einzige Auswahl
kommt mit einem kleinen Salat bisschen
Reis geil eigentlich Chili con Carne ist
Entschuldigung 27 Euro 40 heute lassen
wir es uns gut gehen das ganze Büro hat
bestimmt schon Lust zu essen wir
bestellen und dann wird getestet unsere
erste Bestellung bei Mut so ist
angekommen und ich sag mal so viel das
ging unfassbar schnell unter 20 Minuten
auch das ist ja schon Pluspunkt finde
ich für ein Restaurant bevor wir
angefangen haben schon mal eine positive
Überraschung das hier ist unser Burger
er sieht anders aus als auf dem Foto das
ist wirklich eine andere Burger der hat
nämlich dieses Standard sesamann und der
auf dem Foto hatte so ein selfmade bei
mir ne mein allererster Eindruck das ist
so ein Burger den man so im Schwimmbad
bekommt auch für 5 € na ja das soll ich
sagen also das Patty sieht wirklich sehr
sehr traurig aus unfassbar trocken das
Gemüse scheint relativ frisch darauf zu
sein und es ist kein Käse dabei auf dem
Foto bei Käse haben die einfach
irgendein Foto von einem Cheeseburger
genommen
bisher alles ein bisschen Eigenart
eine negative Bewertung einfließen
würden also abseits der Lieferung die
schnell war war bisher wenig Positives
dabei probiere die alte Kiste mal hier
es ist einfach wirklich ein Schwimmbad
Burger naja der Burger ist halt genau
das was er ist also Industriebahn fertig
Patty alles was da jemals gelebt haben
könnte wurde tot gegrillt aber das
Gemüse ist frisch würde ich mir noch mal
bestellen
nein auf keinen Fall habe ich übel
Hunger ja schmeckt deshalb schlecht nein
also auch das schmeckt mir gerade
einfach gut welche Übungen
der Burger war jetzt wirklich nicht so
nice aber vielleicht kann der Milchreis
etwas auch wirklich eine wilde
Kombination boah das sieht ehrlich aus
finde ich oder
Zimt
Milchreis auch falsch machen kann frage
ich mich auch wirklich weil das kommt ja
so aus der Tüte oder nicht
machen ja okay aber
drauf
die wir machen konnten weil Milchreis
und Burger was willst Du darüber sein
ich frage mich bei solchen Restaurants
ob die keine Bewertung haben weil die
sich immer wieder löschen und dann
wieder neue kommen mit einem etwas
anderen Namen oder ob sie wirklich halt
neu sind deshalb vielleicht sehen die
Leute das ja sogar als Kritik kein Held
Kritik beim Bäcker beziehen geiles Patty
machen die anderen Zutaten sind frisch
so ein bisschen kreativ rangehen keine
fertige Soße draufhauen dann wird das
auch deutlich besser Burger der
Milchreis besser als im Supermarkt
gekauft insgesamt war das eine iPhone 10
deshalb auf zur nächsten Bestellung die
sollte auch jeden Moment da sein ich bin
gespannt ob es kulinarisch vielleicht
etwas anspruchsvoller wird ist ja nicht
besonders schwer ne los geht's ihr seht
in meinen Videos dass ich häufig und
sehr gerne bestelle deshalb freue ich
mich umso mehr über meinen Partner der
mich schon seit über zwei Jahren
unterstützt und zwar sie helfen euch bei
euren Einkäufen in rund
1800 Online Shops bares Geld zu sparen
gerade heutzutage wo wirklich alles
teurer geworden ist ist das eine super
Sache über meinen Link in der
Videobeschreibung kriegt ihr statt den
5,10 € Startguthaben und wenn ihr euch
bis Sonntag anmeldet sogar 15 €, aber
wie funktioniert die gerade ihr kauft
einen im Internet bei Volt bei
Lieferando bei Acers oder bucht eine
Reise über booking igra kriegt von den
Partnershops eine Vermittlungsprovision
für deinen Einkauf mit dir und du
kriegst einen Großteil davon
ausgezeichnet so ist das Ganze also eine
Win-Win-Situation du kriegst Geld vom
Einkaufen zurück egal hat auch was davon
sobald 20 Euro zusammengekommen sind
könnt ihr euch euer Cashback auszahlen
lassen egal ob aufs Bankkonto oder aufs
PayPal Konto ihr könnt über App oder
Browser einen Shop heraussuchen klickt
ihn an und plötzlich könnt ihr wieder
ganz normal einkaufen das Cashback lässt
sich dann mit einem Klick aktivieren
ohne dass man die Seite verlassen muss
über meinen Link in der
Videobeschreibung kriegt ihr statt den
5,10 € Startguthaben und wenn ihr euch
bis Sonntag anmeldet sogar 15 € ladet
euch egal runter geht auf die Website
und probiert das ganze einfach mal aus
wir hätten es ahnen können das Sushi kam
natürlich nicht irgendwie einfach so
geliefert ich hatte jetzt mittlerweile
schon Gaumen Blut Steffen Henssler go
und in Hamburg jetzt das Sushi die sehen
dann schon immer fancy aus aber wie
sieht's darin aus gucken wir gemeinsam
rein hier haben wir also was wir
bestellt haben drin es haut mich jetzt
nicht krank um auf den ersten Blick aber
eigentlich war ich am allermeisten
gespannt
auf diese tiktok Gurke hast du die noch
nie gesehen die Jungs die immer damit so
schwarzen Handschuhen Kochen haben immer
diese Gurken Alter die riechen unnormal
nach dem Sesamöl was wir auch beim
Chicken Teriyaki benutzt haben aber die
werden einfach so eingeschnitten dass
sie so sicher auffächer sehr gut aus wie
du das machst
ein bisschen weniger Geschmack von der
Marinade an als man denken würde
das ist mehr so ein heftig Snack als
einfach übelst lecker und es sieht halt
cool aus deshalb ist es vielleicht auch
so viral also ist ja auch sowas wie
Essig drin oder so gar nicht er hat doch
Spaß zu essen weil es so geil Crunch und
so aber für 7 € würde ich mir nicht noch
was 7 € zwei Gürkchen die ganze
Bestellung war mit Lieferkosten über 40
€. das ist natürlich übelst teuer also
teuer
schmeckt ja auch schon nach fast nichts
als dieser Sesam Geschmack schmeckt
trotzdem nach Gurke 7 Euro
schauen wir also mal wie das so ist
hoffentlich sein Geld wert starten wir
mit dem absoluten Klassiker lachsmaki
man sieht schön viel Fisch drin aber 8
€. weißt du worauf ich immer achte
seitdem ihr dieses Sushi getestet habt
ich achte mal übelst auf die
reiskonsistenz weil darauf habe ich nie
geachtet bei Sushi und bis jetzt hat
sich noch keins was mich so umgehauen
hat alles war übelst weich der ist nicht
so die haben jetzt keinen können bis
mehr so wirklich aber so ein leichten
Widerstand sehr geil
innen drin schmeckt sehr gut Thunfisch
auch hier wieder nicht geizt
beide Magie Thunfisch und Lachs sind
ohne Probleme unter den fünf besten die
wahrscheinlich hatte auch unter dem zwei
teuersten wahrscheinlich die ich bisher
hatte also das ist eine
götterkombination Mango Frischkäse
Avocado Lachs die muss wirklich gut sein
14 Euro glaube
alles was wir hatten wir nehmen mal die
Gurken jetzt aus war geschmacklich
zwischen 9 und 10 schmeckt super gut ist
auch wahrscheinlich so mit einem der
besten Ausführungen von Sushi das
einzige was er darüber schwebt ist der
Preis mega teuer deshalb tue ich mich
ein bisschen schwer bei der Bewertung
ich habe eine gute zu bekommen essen
darf teuer sein die Frage ist ob du
teures Essen bestellen möchtest oder
wenn du schon den Preis bezahlst nicht
lieber im Restaurant die experience hast
weil ich glaube der gleiche Preis im
Restaurant gibt dir viel mehr als in so
einem Pappkarton im Büro vielleicht
richtet sich das Lieferangebot auch an
keine Ahnung Leute in teuren
Anwaltskanzleien die sich irgendwie was
wildes in der Mittagspause gönnen wollen
ich würde da jetzt auch nicht normal
bestellen ich würde bei sowas eher
bestellen wenn ich so ein Date haben
würde so dann würde ich das machen aber
so normal bestellt
insgesamt 8,5 von 10 Enchilada mexicana
gemischter deutscher Beilagensalat vom
mexikanischen Restaurant steigert mein
Vertrauen in diese Bestellung nicht
unbedingt nett aber irgendwas bekommt
weil ich glaube das wird nirgendwo
genannt würde ich sagen
mit starten wir
quada so aus sieht so bisschen nach Paco
Kit aus Enchiladas sehen so aus ja okay
das sieht auch Fische aus wenn das ganze
ausgepackt ist muss man schon sagen das
sieht noch mal anders aus ne also der
bunte Reis neben der Enchilada auf
diesem wunderbaren Teller dann wird das
anders aber das hier drüben sieht aber
auch traurig aus wir machen mal auf
Käse ist anscheinend hier oben an den
Deckel das Tortilla geschmolzen von
unten das ganze nicht ganz so
durchgeweicht wie ich zuerst dachte
diesen einen Kessler dir bestellt haben
mal und der uns so weggeflasht hat genau
sowas habe ich mir erhofft
ja ich weiß nicht Alter ich finde es
schade ich bin wirklich auf der Suche
nach dem Sport wo ich vielleicht auch
bestellen kann geiles mexikanisches
Essen ich liebe mexikanische Küche viele
Leute die da bestellen denke
wahrscheinlich okay aber Mexikaner
gegessen es ist nicht authentisch auf
jeden Fall finde ich ein bisschen schade
schmeckt aber auch nicht schlecht sehr
traurig ja ich hatte so auf eine geile
positive Überraschung gehabt oder dass
das teure noch geiler ist als wir
dachten halt mega geil ist so für seinen
Preis das ist meine letzte Hoffnung
jetzt fällt mir auch auf Maismehl zu dir
ich habe so ein weizen- wie bei der
casada ist nicht prinzipiell nicht
mexikanisch aber hier hast du direkt
halt so einen authentischen Geschmack
mit im Mix drin ich mache mir auf jeden
Fall deutlich besser als die kasada ist
aber auch auf jeden Fall nicht so dass
authentisch mexikanische Gericht wovon
ich träume aber was sollten wir erwarten
Bro so wir haben ja heute nicht beim
besten Burger nicht beim besten Sushi
nicht beim besten Mexikaner bestellt
sondern
bestellt wir sind bestimmt sehr verwöhnt
das muss man auch sagen wir haben sehr
sehr viel krasses Essen gegessen was man
auch sagen muss wir kriegen auf jeden
Fall große Portionen für faire Preise
wenn ich den ganzen Laden bewerben
müsste ob sie ein halbes Jahr wenn man
bei Neueröffnung bestellt darf man
natürlich nicht nur erwarten dass man
immer das allerbeste bekommt was man
sich nur wünschen kann ich habe das
ganze heute fair bewertet ich hoffe ihr
konntet meine Bewertung nachvollziehen
handelt das Video unterhaltsam als ja
das gerne ein Like da abonniert den
Kanal und falls euch das hier drüben
neugierig gemacht hat kann auch mal die
Beschreibung gucken bis zum nächsten mal
vielen Dank noch mal macht's gut und
ciao